Okay. Like, this is my podcast.
Can I ask you how your feelings on pubic hair? I want a gun.
You want none of that child?
Exactly. Yeah. I,
I personally don't mind appeal. I don't want it.
[inaudible] I don't mind a full Bush.
I think they Kush the reason why is I think the first porn that I started to
watch, like that the porn that was taped around, uh, that was passed around.
Cause you know, it should be VHS. Yeah. Um, the women had full bushes. Yeah.
So I just, and I enjoyed it. I was, you know, yeah. It was, um,
it was full Bush porn and uh,
so I don't mind it to be honest with the dough.
I can't tell you the last time I've been with a woman. Who's had pubes. I mean,
I don't, I don't think people don't do it anymore.
I've been toying with growing my back lately.
I, you wouldn't, it wouldn't deter me. I mean, styles are cyclical. I love it.
I love a Bush. I love a book.
It's not, I don't, I have zero. Like I'm not out here getting bikini.
Wax is for any man or anything just for comfortability.
Like it just gets itchy down there. It's just annoying. Right.
And the bikini season comes. It's a mess. Yeah. So it's really just like, yeah.
When I was with my kid's mom,
I wasn't allowed to shave my pubes because then she would think like,
if I shaved my pubes, I was going to have sex with somebody. So,
so now that I've been single, I just, I have, I have the biggest push. I mean,
I have full Bush blocker. That's I bet you that's. One of those years,
one of those hairs got my ear. What do you guys like to like Bush?
I just want you to maintain what you have going on. I've never had a situation.
I don't know. Tell me if you have,
I've never had a situation where I've gone down there and been like, Holy,
something's wrong. You know, I've just never been with a guy that didn't like,
manscape I have one guy. I remember like running my fingers through it,
to cross out a little bit. It was too much like when you like wise guy to shirt,
Trent. So can I sell this story?
His friends called him to short Trent and they were like,
he only has two shirts actually. And I'm like, that's gotta be an exaggeration.
I thought it was cause he wore two shirts at a time at all times.
And I was like, that's ridiculous. And then one day I slept over at his place.
Finger come this Butte pubes the night before he went to work and he was like,
stay here, let yourself out. We actually live in the same apartment complex.
He was like, stay here, let yourself out whenever. And I was like, okay.
And I was like, I'm going to open that closet. One shirt on a hanger.
So one shirt on him, one shirt on a hanger. And I called my friend.
I wasn't get over here. He really owns two shirts.
And then for my birthday, he really liked me.
And he bought himself a third shirt.
That was a big day for him right there. And he had a full Bush. This kid?
Yes. But I was like, I feel like I don't like him at all. I'm like,
I need to break up with him. And my friend, Karen was like Ashley.
He was friends with her boyfriend. She was like, Chad told me,
Karen and Chad there. She was like,
Chad told me that he tried them all getting a shirt for your birthday.
I was like, I keep bringing up with this guy. Like,
he was like, I got, I got a shirt.
I got the only other shirt that I own for this. Did you dump them though?
Anyway. Yeah. We like, I usually I used to do and I still am.
She waited till I paid off the credit card bill that month
just get really wasted and like burn it to the ground. Yeah.
You just do something so crazy.
Yeah. Who only owned two shirt?
I was expect that kid to not manscape if he took care of everything else in the
rest of his life, but he only had.
Right. I like to know what guys are really doing down there. Like, is it a, uh,
like a, uh, like an electric shaver? I use a Mach three in the shower. Yeah.
W wash after that.
And then I just rub like a whole bunch of lotion on it or something. I go,
if I shave, no, if I'm going to full Bush, then I just wash my Bush.
Like my hair just falls, not shave my body,
shape it in the shower. I shave, I don't put shaving cream on my Dick and balls.
I just, while the shower is running, I'll just shave. Okay.
Not too hairy. But um, I shaved my balls. Yeah. With the, with the razor.
I just feel, I don't like going out in the world without shape balls. Yeah.
My moods on top.
It's not itchy. Not at you at all.
He also leads
[inaudible] and he cleans the inside of his.
It's like hydrogen peroxide, but it puts it in his. My butt has been itching.
A little more witch, Hazel, witch, Hazel, which by the way, our fans real quick,
our fans have said, uh, put the witch Hazel in the refrigerator.
It's a cold witch. Hazel works better. Okay.
How do you, how do you get it in your bag? She's been showering.
It's clean. I can testify Jane A. Little bit. I think you've got to witch.
Hazel, your. So you put it up your or does your wife do it?
Not yet. She hasn't yet, but when we get more, yeah. Now that we're married,
she has no rights anymore. You guys are married. Hey exactly. I traded,
I traded three goats for her.
Now she has the witch, Hazel, your with a Q-tip.
You actually penetrate your bottle or you just do the rim.
Take toilet paper. I pour some, which has a lot on it.
And it's one that when I want a 100% clean,
because usually I think you either 90, 90, two, 97%,
shower's not going to get you 100% clean. Not in America, not in America,
shower head. So you can get that a problem in America. You know, they,
you can't bring the party.
I could do it in my, in my kitchen though.
I have a removable hose in my kitchen so I can, I can, yeah.
You're sure you can climb up there and me. Oh, no doubt. I can fit in the sink.
Yeah. I use a loaf as whole,
but now what people send in our pockets that loofahs are filled with bacteria
and they're disgusting.
Oh yeah. Can I do it?
Like I'll do it on like my fingertip and just kind of go around my.
You can get creative, but then whole foods or up your whole study.
It's your own style, Amazon. And I'll also have,
and over the final frontier of friendship, I'll witch, Hazel, your.
You guys know how you bleach an. So I,
at my old bikini waxing place used in Atlanta,
she started doing bleachings and I was like, how do you do it? And she was like,
you literally just have to rim around until,
until it's bleached with actually, okay. I have a crazy question.
What do they drop massage the bleach into your.
It's actually.
Have like some girls have like a Brown.
Residue. It's just there.
Yeah. My bud is like the same color through and through.
I'm just I'm pink all the way. Your. I have explored every crevice of my body.
It's all the same color. We'll have some Brown down.
I know what would be the I like, I.
Don't know, just like a skin. I mean, your skin is different colors.
Yeah, but I mean like skin. Okay. If I had,
if I had something on my skin that I, but like, I mean,
who's seeing the inside of your. I understand people's stories.
Not the inside. It's around the Ram. It's a different color. So yeah.
In other words, like in a bikini, you'd be able to see a Brown, huh?
No, only if you,
so if I bent over and I like spread my cheeks out and you're staring into my
star, the color of the star would be like a different color.
Well would be getting around. So bleach,
if she thinks she's going to be having sex from the bed, like
never had about sex ever in my life.
Not once. Okay. Yeah. We should date. That sounds great.
I've never done it. I've never done it. I've tried to finagle it in a girl's,
but it just doesn't work. And I'd read like, you in your ear then your
lubricated. No, I don't like it. It's it's not. Nah, it's dry. Yeah. I don't,
I'm not a big fan. I've never eaten an either. I've never done anything with a,
but I've got warmed up and licked a few asks.
I had one girl.
Against my will stick her finger in my, um,
and was blowing me and stuck her finger in my.
And it was against my will initially. But it did feel really good.
I like it at first because like, you,
you have to be warned when it's going to happen. You got to warm it up.
I was like, Whoa, Whoa.
It feels like, just relax. But you know what people say?
You know what my theory on that is? People say like, Oh, you like a finger?
It's like, yeah. I like a finger in my when I'm getting my Dick sucked.
So I think the Dick suck is the big part of that. Like,
you can shoot me in the head while you suck my Dick. I'll be like,
I like getting shot in the head with my kids. You know what I mean?
I disagree. Men have you've nerve endings in your prostate.
So you have like a Clint in your butt. You have, um, we call it button your,
but you have to call it a. Taurus.
Taurus. That's hilarious. We really hope you enjoyed that episode.
Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe, uh,
turn on your notifications. Get jiggy with it.
Go to patrion.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really wild.